Also ich kann's auch jetzt langsam verstehen warum die Leute das von dir gefordert haben und ich find's auch cool, dass du Dupes ausprobiert hast!
Hallöchen ihr Lieben!
Heute komme ich einem Wunsch nach denn seit Wochen bzw. Monaten schreibt ihr mir
hier unten in den Kommentaren aber auch ganz viel auf Instagram ob ich nicht den Lotus Cheesecake machen kann.
Für die, die's vielleicht nicht wissen: Die Lotus Creme ist ein Brotaufstrich mit Spekulatiusgeschmack.
Jetzt denkt ihr wahrscheinlich: "Okay, jetzt ist ja grade nicht Winter!"
Aber das ist auch so ein Cheesecake, der schmeckt das ganze Jahr über sehr lecker
und ich mag ihn am liebsten gekühlt.
Jetzt habe ich mir überlegt: Wir machen das Ganze mit einer anderen Creme,
nämlich der Karamellgebäck-Creme von Kaufland.
Die schmeckt der Lotus Creme sehr ähnlich und ich hab gedacht:
"Okay, wir machen das Ganze mit Dupes!"
Genauso wie ich auch nicht die Lotus Kekse verwende, denn das sind Karamellkekse der Firma Lotus.
Ich nehme einfach einen Dupe.
Bei Kaufland findet ihr übrigens sowohl die Markenprodukte als auch die Eigenmarken
oder halt abweichende Produkte, die dem Ganzen dann schon ganz nahe kommen.
So, ich hab jetzt hier meine 20cm Springform.
Falls ihr das irgendwie umrechnen möchtet und sagt: "Hey, ich möchte lieber eine 26er Torte machen",
dann verlinke ich euch meine Umrechnungstabelle unten in der Infobox
genauso wie alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben.
Ich nehme jetzt hier ganz einfach mein Backpapier und kleide den Boden aus
und danach brauchen wir noch Alufolie.
Und ich erkläre euch dann später im Schritt warum das so wichtig ist.
So, wichtig ist, dass ihr jetzt bei der Springform den Rand noch mit einkleidet.
Meine Springform ist schon sehr, sehr auslaufsicher aber wir legen das gleich in ein Wasserbad,
daher tut mir den Gefallen und macht das sicherheitshalber.
Und geht auch gerne bis zum Rand damit wir später auch Risse vermeiden.
Und ich mache jetzt im nächsten Schritt schonmal den Boden, der besteht aus Karamellkeksen und geschmolzener Butter.
[Hamza] Wie heißen die bei Kaufland?
Stereo heißen die oder dann eben Lotus oder halt anderes Karamellgebäck!
Und ihr dürft auch die Kekse gerne gegen andere trockene Kekse austauschen!
Sei es jetzt Butterkekse, Kakaokekse, und, und, und!
Also dieses Rezept ist mega variabel merke ich gerade!
Den Keksboden jetzt einfach schön andrücken und dann kurz zur Seite stellen.
Und jetzt rühre ich die Cheesecakemasse zusammen. Leute - Super easy!
Einfach alle Zutaten zusammenrühren!
Es macht Sinn, wenn die Zutaten wirklich Zimmertemperatur haben
damit sie sich besser verbinden und jetzt keine Klümpchen oder so enthalten sind.
Und ich fange an mit Eiern, Zucker, und Vanilleextrakt,
fange an, das zu Rühren, gebe dann Doppelrahmfrischkäse und Quark dazu
und danach siebe ich noch Speisestärke mit in die Masse.
So, zu guter letzt gebe ich noch was von dem Aufstrich rein,
verrühre das auch nochmal schön glatt und gebe das dann auf meinen Keksboden.
So, ich habe meine Creme jetzt hier nochmal so ein bisschen aufgewärmt im Wasserbad
weil je nachdem, wie ihr sie lagert, ist sie halt ein bisschen fester und dann könntet ihr Klümpchen bekommen.
Und um das zu vermeiden einfach in ein Wasserbad stellen und dann nochmal unterrühren.
Übrigens ist auch die Reihenfolge, wie ihr die Zutaten für den Cheesecake vermengt, vollkommen egal!
Hauptsache - das ist mir wichtig - ihr rührt nicht zu viel und schlagt nicht zu viel Luft ein.
Meine Masse ist jetzt perfekt, ich rühre auch nicht unnötig lange
und fülle das jetzt eben ein, streiche das nochmal kurz glatt
und dann gebe ich das in den vorgeheizten Backofen, 160° C Ober- und Unterhitze für 45min.
Allerdings werde ich euch gleich am Backofen auch nochmal einen Trick zeigen, wie ihr dann Risse vermeiden könnt.
So, jetzt habe ich nochmal kochendes Wasser in das Backblech gegeben, ca- 2cm hoch.
Also ihr braucht jetzt nicht so genau drauf zu achten.
Wichtig ist, dass ihr eben kochendes Wasser reingebt damit die Oberfläche schön gleichmäßig ist.
Nach den 45min bei 160° C bitte einen Holzkochlöffel
oder einen hitzebeständigen Silikonkochlöffel zwischen die Ofentür klemmen,
die Temperatur komplett runterschalten und nochmal 20min im Ofen lassen
und anschließend könnt ihr ihn rausnehmen und dann zeige ich euch die weitere Deko.
Bis gleich!
Den Cheesecake lasst ihr dann vollständig auskühlen
und dann bitte nochmal für 3h in den Kühlschrank.
Mindestens 3h, gerne auch über Nacht!
Der muss wirklich komplett durchziehen und dann schmeckt er am allerbesten!
Für den Guss wird dann nur noch der restliche Aufstrich erwärmt.
Das macht ihr am besten in einem Wasserbad, solange bis er schön fließt.
Und dann gebt ihr den einfach auf die Oberfläche und dekoriert das Ganze noch
mit kleingemixten Keksen wenn ihr mögt und ich gebe dann gerne noch 2 Kekse obendrauf.
Aber das ist komplett euch überlassen!
Ich würde mich an der Stelle verabschieden aber ihr sollt unbedingt noch dranbleiben
denn selbst ich bin gespannt, wie du Hamza jetzt dein Urteil fällst beim Taste Test!
Ähm ja, lasst das einfach mal auf euch wirken!
So, macht's gut ihr Lieben und bis zum nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen! Tschüss!
[Hamza] Das riecht schon richtig mega gut! Ich probier's direkt, ne?
[Kiki] M-hm!
[Hamza] M-hm, m-hm, m-hm!
[Hamza] Ich fühl mich wieder im Winter zurück!
[Hamza] Es ist zwar immer noch kalt aber - Ja, ist halt typisch Spekulatius, ne?
[Hamza] Der Boden, der ist schön knackig.
[Hamza] Die Creme - äh der Käsekuchen an sich, der Cheesecake ist von der Höhe finde ich optimal
[Hamza] so wenn man's vergleicht mit dem Boden, Creme und dann die Glasur.
[Hamza] Ja, vom Geschmack her...
[Hamza] Also der, der Spekulatius oder Karamellkekse liebt, ist auf jeden Fall hier richtig!
[Hamza] Also hier kriegst du wirklich die volle Dröhnung Spekulatius!
[Hamza] Und das nochmal im Teig, also in der Creme, ne?
[Kiki] Ja, im Cheesecake ist das auch nochmal drin.
[Hamza] Das schmeckt man einfach raus! Und deswegen auch diese etwas dunklere Note in der Creme, ne?
[Hamza] Also Leute, schmeckt sehr, sehr gut! Wirklich sehr, sehr gut!
[Hamza] Unbedingt nachmachen!
[Hamza]Also ich kann's auch jetzt langsam verstehen warum die Leute das von dir gefordert haben!
[Hamza] Und ich find's auch cool, dass du Dupes ausprobiert hast!
[Hamza] Weil ich hab schon mal einen Cheesecake probiert mit Lotus, ich hab jetzt da keinen Unterschied gemerkt.
[Hamza] Vom Geschmack her ist es recht ähnlich. Ist nicht genau gleich aber ist recht ähnlich!
[Hamza] Also Leute! Das heißt für euch: Ab zu Kaufland, nachmachen,
[Hamza] liken, abonnieren...
[Hamza] Liken, abonnieren!
[Hamza] Mir fällt's einfach runter!
[Hamza] Liken, abonnieren und natürlich - Ja, das war's eigentlich für heute, ne?
[Hamza] Peace and out! Ich genieß das noch und viel Spaß!
[Kiki] Man hat dein Peace nicht gesehen, du warst zu weit oben mit deiner Hand! *lacht*
[Hamza] Gemeistert!
[Hamza] Aber ganz kurz:
[Kiki] Oh-oh, jetzt hab ich Angst!
[Hamza] Bevor ich abschließe musst du noch probieren, du hast gar nicht probiert!
[Kiki] Ja stimmt!
[Hamza] Ich will ganz kurz deine Meinung dazu hören!
[Kiki] Okay!
[Hamza] Und? Und? Und?
[Kiki] Boah! Mmmh!
[Kiki] Boah, richtig lecker!
[Kiki] Ich hab so ein wohlwolliges Gefühl im Bauch wenn ich das esse wenn ich ehrlich bin!
[Hamza] Schmeckt gut, ne?
[Kiki] Schmeckt richtig lecker und sehr cremig!
[Hamza] Sehr cremig! Ja, das ist es! Das ist das Wort, das mir gefehlt hat gerade. Sehr cremig!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Leute! So, dat reicht jetzt für heute!
[Hamza] Mach mal aus, ne? Ich will jetzt mal essen!
[Kiki] Tschüüss!
[Hamza] Alles meins!
[Kiki] *lacht*